if we begin this morning with the
collapse of the Republican effort to
repeal or replace the Affordable Care
Act also known as Obamacare since the
ACA was signed into law seven years ago
the GOP has worked to unwind it but on
Friday Republican leaders pulled their
replacement bill called the American
healthcare act from the House floor when
it became clear they did not have the
votes to support it president Trump
blamed the Democrats for the failure of
the ahc a while White House Speaker Paul
Ryan while House Speaker Paul Ryan tried
to play down the policy differences
within the Republican ranks both said
they are ready to move on to another
issue Errol Barnett is at the White
House with the latest Errol good morning
good morning despite and join control of
both the executive and legislative
branches here in Washington Republicans
have failed to deliver on a key campaign
promise to repeal and replace Obamacare
president Trump's first major
legislative test ended in failure and
the White House says it wants to move on
now and tackle other subjects but there
are clear indications the man who
proclaims to be the dealmaker in chief
is seeing his limitations we were very
close it was a very very tight margin
from the White House President Trump
conceded Friday his effort to repeal and
replace Obamacare was dead a stinging
loss despite his dire predictions I want
great health care for the people of the
station but it can't do well it's
imploding and soon will explode and it's
not gonna be pretty I think the losers
are Nancy Pelosi and Chuck children
because now they own Obamacare they own
it I alone can fix it it's a far cry
from one of his cornerstone themes
during the presidential campaign we are
going to repeal and replace horrible
disasters Obamacare which he repeated
earlier this month in Tennessee's your
senators just told me that in your state
you're down to practically no ensures
you can have nobody Obamacare is the law
of the land we're gonna be living with
Obamacare for the foreseeable future
instead of holding the vote is expected
Friday afternoon
House Speaker Paul Ryan explained the
gops collective fail and finally
consensus I will not sugarcoat this this
is a disappointing day for us Ryan
suggested the bill be pulled when he
knew the conservative freedom caucus had
not been convinced by additional White
House concessions still mr. Trump said
he does not blame the members of the
freedom caucus I'm not betrayed their
friends of mine I'm disappointed because
we could have had it some conservatives
opposed the bill because it didn't go
far enough in repealing Obamacare while
moderate Republicans say it went too far
and could leave 24 million Americans
without insurance over the next decade
the president who acknowledged he didn't
like parts of the American Health Care
Act suggested he is now open to
negotiating on reforms with the
opposition I honestly believe the
Democrats will come to us and say look
let's get together and get a great
health care bill or plan it's pretty
exciting for us Democrats said they are
open to working with the President to
build on the current law if repeal is
taken off the table let's just for a
moment breathe a sigh of relief for the
American people that the Affordable Care
Act was not repealed now there are other
yet to be delivered promises by the
Trump administration during its first
100 days construction of a border wall
infrastructure spending and tax reform
the ladder is the president's next
priority and all of this dawn while the
executive travel bans remain held up by
the federal courts all right arrow
Barnett at the White House thank you